大家好
我是史蒂夫考夫曼 (Steve Kaufmann)
今天呢
我要用中文给大家讲一个问题
关于中文 学中国话的一个问题
就是说呢
学中国话容易不容易
我觉得这个或者是难不难
你们喜欢我的这个视频
请你们订阅或者是在这个铃铛的时候
点击可以收到通知
好
那么今天有人讲一讲这个问题
哪一个语言是容易学
哪一个语言是难学的呢
那么多半的
特别是可能是西方人会认为中国话呢
中文是比较难学
那我要提出一些
一些因素会影响到那个问题
就是说会影响到
是不是中文是难学或者是容易学
我想有主观的因素
也有客观的因素
主观的因素呢
有你的态度
我觉得学任何语言呢态度是最重要
所以假如你非常愿意学中文
那么中文的所谓客观的难度
都不成问题了
那也是对任何一种语言
你非常要学习这个外语
那问题就不成问题了
没有什么
难关会障碍你了
所以你愿意不愿意学
我觉得是一个非常重要的一个主观因素
还有你认为自己可以学到这门外语
比如说你假如认为而且我也碰见过
别的加拿大人 西方人认为
中文、中国话太难了
可是呢实际上有很多
就是外国人不是中国人
是成功的
把中国话学到非常流利的水平
所以我觉得这种
有把握有自信心呢 我可以
这个也是一个非常重要的一个主观的因素
还有呢
你会不会激动
比如说我
学习中文的时候
我是经常去书店找一些新的材料
那是50年前的事情
那个时候没有互联网
没有那么丰富的学习语言的材料
所以我是去那些书店找
对我来讲是比较
适合我的兴趣
和我的水平的一些教科材料
我是激动的
当然在各方面要激动
所以要是你是等到那先生会教这个给你
那就可能中文会难一点
但是你假如是愿意学
有把握有激动
我想这问题不大了
另外一个呢
我觉得学习中文
是因为有一些客观的难处呢
我想要集中的学
我学了中文的时候我每天
六七个钟头就学了中文
要不是看书就是练习写字了
或者是跟老师说话了
或者是听一些录音带了
就是差不多每一天六七个钟头
非常的集中地学
我觉得任何一种语言是
集中地学比较好
但是有些语言特别是中文
我想特别需要你集中地去学
所以这也是一个主观的一个因素
那客观的因素也不少
比如说呢我想学习中文
最重要或者是最大的一个难关呢
应该算是汉字
因为学习任何一种语言
假如这个文字呢
和你所习惯的文字
或者是一样的拉丁文字
或者是比较近
像这个俄语用的
不知道叫什么 西里尔字母 (Cyrillic)
问题不大
但是中国话有很多很多
这个汉字要学习
因为我想
因为看书是对学习语言
一个非常重要的一种学习的方法
一个活动
所以你要认识
两千三千四千个字才可以看
小说 看报纸什么的
所以这个汉字是一个
比较大的一个客观的难关 (难度)
但是也是因为这个原因就是要集中地学
因为那汉字呢
需要学习三千四千个汉字
每一个汉字它会有
从两三个笔画到十五个笔画
所以这个不容易
而且为了能认识那些字
至少我学了这个汉字的时候
我是用手写那些汉字
现在不会写
用手写不可以
但是用电脑可以
但是就是一个过程
也就是要费很多时间
但是所以
就是因为这个原因要集中地学
因为呢你学这个汉字一学就忘了
那这个当然学习其他语言也是
任何生字
你学习一个生字一定
肯定要忘了的 以后要再学要忘再忘了
这是一种学习的过程
但是这个在学习中文是特别重要
这是一个客观的这个难度
另外呢中文它是有这个
四声声调
这个不只是中文有好多
所谓英文叫声调语言 (tonal languages)
当然我们在英文或者其他的别的语言
我们也有点不同声调
但是这种声调呢
不是按照声调这个字的这个意思会变
而是在某一个句子里头是为了
就是某一个
某一个字或者某一个意思就是跟那个
就是声调的这个用法跟中文不一样
所以这是没有这种习惯的人会认为
学习这个四声中文的四声mā  má  mǎ  mà
是个问题
但是这也是习惯的问题
所以要多听
多愿意就可以了
另外一个客观的这个因素呢
学习任何语言呢
是有没有足够的有意思的
就是学习的内容材料
实际上我不知道在中文
但是我估计现在有不少
过去我学的时候没有互联网
所以...但是就算那个时候也有不少的
有意思的材料
所以我觉得这应该是
一个好的那个
好的一个因素
另外呢
你学会了中文的足够的汉字的话呢
增加这个词汇量
就比别的语言容易点
因为每一个所谓生字
所谓新的那个短语
新的这个词
普通的时候是有
两个或者是三个字构成的
所以你认识
你这新的字
生字里头你认识一个字你可以
猜这个字是什么意思
或者可能是对你来讲是一个新的
我们英文叫 word
一个新的生字呢
但是呢里头的那两个汉字你已经认识
所以你会比较容易的记住
这个新的字的这个意思
所以我总认为
中文虽然
他那个词汇量
词汇和我们比如说英文完全不一样
不像我是
我会西方亚语要学习意大利语
差不多80%以上的
那个词汇是差不多一样的
在中文没有这种
免费可以拿出来的这个绳子
是个问题
但是在学习中文的时候你认识的字
越来越多的话呢
那你可以猜
或者至少比较容易记住
新的字的这个意思
所以这也是一个好的方面
另外呢中国的文化
不是太复杂的
比如说比这个斯拉夫语言
俄语什么的
比它简单的多
我明天去
昨天去了
或者说现在去 你去我去他去
这个字不会变
也没有这个性别 (gender) 男的女的没有
所以我觉得在这个文化方面
是比较容易学
我完全在学习中文的时候没有
有些关于文化的一些词
我完全不理他们
无所谓，就是要多听
有些新词慢慢的会习惯
所以我觉得在文化方面
中国话是比较容易
比我学过的别的语言比较容易
所以总而言之
中文、中国话难不难
是有主观的和客观的因素
假如你这个主观的你态度上
这个东西不够的话
你是会被那些
客观的难处 会受到影响
让你认为中国话是难的
但是你有足够的这种积极的态度
愿意喜欢有把握
那么那些中国话的所谓难的地方
不会就是挡不住你了
所以希望没有开始学习中文的那些人
会以我这个视频稍微感觉到鼓励
愿意要学
因为要是你有这种态度的话
中国话肯定不是难学
Okay
谢谢大家 再见